Mind your Decisions, I'm Presh Talwalkar.
What is the value of the following sum?
Burger King® asked this problem on Twitter.
The value of the sum would be a promo code, that could be used for a free Whopper with any purchase.
To avoid spoiling the answer,
I'm going to solve a slightly different problem to illustrate the method of how you would solve such a problem.
So, what is the value of the following sum:
-Σ(i=1 -> 100) (-1)^i *((5!*5)/4!)^1/2.
Pause if you'd like to give this problem a try, and when you're ready, keep watching to learn how to solve this problem.
So, how can we solve this problem?
We'll get started by simplifying 5!/4!.
5! = 5 x 4 x 3 x 2 x 1,
and 4! = 4 x 3 x 2 x 1.
We can get 5!/4! by dividing 4! from 5!.
Notice we'll eliminate 4, 3, 2, & 1 in the product. We're left with just 5.
We substitute that in and we have 5 x 5. This will be equal to 5^2.
(5^2)^1/2 = 5, so we can then factor out the 5.
We then want to evaluate the following sum of (-1)^i, where i = 1 -> 100.
We can write these terms out.
Now -1^odd num. = -1, and -1^even num. = 1.
We thus simplify the following terms and we have an alternating sum:
-1+1, and so on and so on until we reach the last pair of -1+1.
So, every pair of terms will actually cancel out to be equal to 0.
Therefore this entire sum will be equal to 0, so we have -5  x 0,
and that's, of course, equal to 0.
It's great to see a big company use mathematics in its social media promotion.
Let me know if you see any other companies using math in their social media!
Thanks for making Mind your Decisions one of the best channels on YouTube. As always, thanks for watching, and thanks for your support.